you've stayed you stayed in my house for
a couple of weeks until we realized a
lot of things have gone very bad
and now you're here and now I'm here
watching my family because I'm the only
boy only man watching my family
my dad is in America right now and we're
we're going there
sometimes I just feel like when I'm
leaving I feel like a traitor to my
country I'm leaving them in all this
pain while I'm going to go and have joy
it's like sometimes you feel like
they're traded for doing that I don't
know why
I robbed I felt to refresh
we were in somewhere safe without
gunshots it's been a while since that
happened a couple of weeks it just
happened all of a sudden gunshots moms
which is very terrible people dying
you know